hello believe nation today I'm gonna
talk about the best seven motivational
quotes to start your day with so staying
motivated is a constant challenge for
entrepreneurs it's just tough waking up
every day yes I mean hopefully you're
doing something you love and your
passion about and you want to get on and
get that hustle going and have that
impact that you're looking for but it's
still hard it's still hard when you're
doing everything alone and you don't
have a team around you you don't have
the resources you want you not seen the
momentum that you want and so staying
motivated is really important and I used
to find them looking up to successful
entrepreneurs kept me motivated and
there were seven quotes that I look to
consistently that helped me stay
motivated stay on my game if I'm feeling
low I can look at them and it kind of
brings me back up and I thought I would
share them with you today to hopefully
give you some motivation and inspiration
to start your day with
so number one is from Steve Jobs the
co-founder of Apple believe that things
will work out follow your intuition and
curiosity trust your heart even when it
leads you off the well-worn path you
have to trust the dots will somehow
connect in the future the only way to do
great work is to love what you do if you
haven't found it yet keep looking don't
settle as with all matters of the heart
you'll know when you find it have the
courage to follow your heart and
intuition they somehow already know what
you want to become everything else is
secondary
number two comes from Oprah Winfrey what
I know for sure is that if you want to
have success you can't make success your
goal the key is not to worry about being
successful but to instead work towards
being significant and the success will
naturally follow if you do work that you
love and work that fulfills you the rest
will come and I truly believe that the
reason I've been able to be so financial
successful is because my focus has never
ever for one minute been money would you
do your job and not be paid for it I
would do this job and take on a second
job just to make ends meet if nobody
paid me that's how you know you're doing
the right thing number three is from
Tony Robbins a real decision is measured
by the fact that you've taken a new
action if there's no action you haven't
truly decided the most important thing
you can do to achieve your goals is to
make sure that as soon as you set them
you immediately begin to create momentum
the most important rules that I ever
adopted to help mean achieving my goals
were those I learned from a very
successful man who taught me the first
write down the goal and then to never
leave the sight of setting the goal
without first taking some form of
positive action towards its attainment
for changes to be of any true value
they've got to be lasting and consistent
any time you sincerely want to make a
change the first thing you must do is
raise your standards if you don't set a
baseline standard to what you'll accept
in life you'll find it's easy to sleep
in the behaviors and attitudes or
quality of life that's far below what
you deserve whatever happens take
responsibility the only thing that's
keeping you from getting what you want
is a story you keep telling yourself
number four is from CNN founder Ted
Turner all my life people have said that
I wasn't gonna make it
you can never quit winners never quit
and quitters never win number five is
from body shop founder Anita Roddick
whatever you do be different that was
the advice my mother gave me and I can't
think a better advice for an
entrepreneur if you're different you
will stand out number six from Four
Seasons Hotel founder Isadora Sharpe
whatever you do don't ever use a crutch
and don't ever think of have an excuse
for not having said yeah I did my best
and number seven is from EA Sports
founder trip Hawkins one quality of
entrepreneurship is just being
consistent not giving up because you
have roadblocks and also not giving in
because other people tell you that
you're nuts you are nuts and you should
be proud of it stick with what you
believe in
so those are my seven best motivational
quotes to start the day with I'm curious
what you guys thought of it which one
did you like the best what resonated the
most with you leave it in the comments
below and I'll join in the discussion
also there are quotes that you really
enjoy that you want to add to the list
you want to put an 8 9 10 on that list
leave in the comments I'm really curious
to see what motivates inspires you guys
finally I want to give a quick shout out
to Damian Calzado from surf bounce calm
didn't even thank you so much for buying
my book really means a lot to me those
are you watching if you want to change
that a shout-out in a future video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon